We have a fan. That's great. Uh, hey
everybody. This is the last talk of the
day. This was an epic day. I learned a
lot today. I wish we wish this
conference was held back in November.
Could have saved me and Glenn a lot of
work along the way. I'm Bob. This is
Glenn. Say hi, Glenn.
>> Hi, Glenn.
>> And uh, we're both on the adver
adversary engineering and R&D side of
Grey Noise. We call ourselves Great Grey
Noise Labs because we're not very clever
about naming things. And uh our team
crafts and deploys detection rules. We
call them tags. Uh we craft detection
environments, which is a really fancy
phrase for we deploy honeypotss. And we
hunt for threat actors and for zero days
in our data. And we're here today to
talk to you about the newest member of
our team, Orbee.
Uh, Orbee is an internal AI powered
thread intelligence analyst that helps
us make sense of what's happening on our
planetary scale global observation grid.
And the truth is, as you're going to
hear, we were overwhelmed trying to find
truly meaningful new signal in all the
noise that we capture. And that's how
Orbee came to be. So, we're going to
talk to you about what Ary is, why we
literally had to build it, the lessons
that we learned while bending it to our
collective will, and the outcomes that
we achieved after building it. And we
may talk about futures if we have time
left. Uh, but we're going to tell you
all we can about our friendly
neighborhood spherical spelunker. And
we've got some goodies to give you as
well. Feel free to go to this right now
because there's some slides you're going
to need to look at the things I'm there
for because we realize these screens
just aren't going to show them. And
you're looking at screens anyway. So
like feel free to do that and all you
Zoom people get to see them before
everybody else. So you guys have fun for
those things. And oh good. I actually
made it big enough. So Orbeez is
actually going to do a threat hunt while
we're talking to you today. It takes
around 14 minutes. So hopefully we'll
get done in time to co-join it. Uh I
found some weird base double base 64
encoded stuff and Orbeez is going to go
look through our fleet of honeypot data
to figure out what it is without me
intervening with it at all. And we'll
show you the progress throughout and
hopefully to be done with this at the
end and we can see what it is. Now,
Orbee turns out to be a reverse origin
story. Normally, the hero causes
villains to be created. In this case,
Orbee was born out of necessity due to
the villain known as React to Shell. Uh,
this is this thing was terrible. How
terrible. This is how terrible. It came
on the scene back in December 2025. It
was bad. It was It wasn't as bad as Log
forj, but it was pretty bad. And this is
just an example of the data that we saw
every single day, the number of sessions
coming in and the onslaught that we had
to deal with ever since then, too,
because this goes to like just last
week. Everybody tried to sling React to
shell payloads out whatever they could
on the internet to get their share of
all the things census inventoried that
was out there for these things. And by
January 6th, we had observed over 8,200
unique IPs from over a thousand ASNs
that were slinging 70,000 completely
unique payloads trying to compromise
react to shell. And I just felt
compelled to note uh this is one of u
more than a few of with the help of
claude AI generated payloads and we can
talk to you about payloads. We have a
site you can go to explore those as well
with massively diverse network
fingerprints. And if Glenn or I had
tried to do this stuff on our own
without the help of something else, it
would have driven us crazy. And as you
can see, Orbee was kind of pissed at us
for having to do this work as well. Uh
so this is Orbee. Uh this is the
nutrition facts for Orbee. If you have
that link up as well, there's a bigger
version of this out there. And we're
going to go through some specifics, but
you can find a lot more in the repo as
well. And uh it runs in a very
customized clog code environment. We're
going to throw that away soon and build
our own because we reached the limits of
what clog code can actually go do. It
coordinates between 12 and 16 MCP
servers and around seven plus
investigation. We are which we are going
to cover a couple here. However, with
all that, it's a really light footprint.
Uh most of the work is done in remote
servers like Archammy or our API. Uh
local duct DB does all the analysis and
you'll see why in a minute. And the LLM
takes care of a lot of work for us as
well too. And the goal for this is to
save us a bunch of time, deliver
structured, reproducible, and validated
that's because of him. Uh thread threat
hunting analyses and other artifacts
that uses our data. And you can see all
the other stuff that we actually have to
go to do that.
Yeah. So Bob started the the story, but
you can, you know, to reframe that
again. Why does Orbeez exist? And it's
because we are tired.
And here's why. as we have a a look at
just a few seconds of uh pecaps and
sessions that we see on our fleet on a
pew pew map because everyone loves pew
maps. That was a hackathon project. Uh
over the just in the last 90 days, we're
looking at three like we have a fleet of
over 3,000 sensors, 90 plus countries,
3,500 detections, 200 attacker profiles,
and those are growing by the week pretty
much. And then underneath all that,
growing by the second, again over the
last 90 days, we're talking 22 tab of
packet captures, 32 tab of session
information, and 20 million elastic
search documents. So this is what one
small team at a startup is responsible
for sifting through the noise to be able
to find the signal to be able to deliver
the protections to our customers and see
what's growing going on on the internet.
So in the end, we scaled our fleets, but
the scale is what broke us. So we built
Orbee.
It's a good thing Orbee never gets
tired.
>> Nope.
>> So one thing I am still stunned by in
2026 is that folks get tripped up that
these LLMs don't come preloaded with
everything you need and they just
dismiss them outright. Even the ones
that have been purpose-built for that,
like I won't mention some of the
Security Foundation models, but they're
not great. We've tried them all and even
these fancy new ones that came out in
November that we're all like singing the
praises of. They're they're good, but
they don't have everything that we need,
as you just heard, too, to do what we
needed to do. And I liken this to the
scene in the Matrix where Tank is
uploading jiu-jitsu into into Neo.
That's the problem that we're trying to
solve that we've all that you've heard
throughout today trying to solve. Orbee
starts with an empty head every single
time, just like Claude does. You can
give it memory, but it still fires up
with an empty head. For our threat
hunting context, it's actually by
default about as smart and helpful as
like a 13-year-old with access to both a
flamethrower and Wikipedia. So, not not
really not really helpful. So, the skill
system is how we load it up. And we have
individual skill directories and each
one is a structured system prompt and
associated resources and tools that
define workflow phases that Orbee is
going through. Now the Orbee that we
fired up before, it's going to go
through about six workflow phases. We
may get to see a little bit of like
workflow two or three as we check in on
in a minute. There's mand there's
mandatory constraints. There's
definitions of antiatterns because you
got to tell it what it shouldn't do, not
just what it should do. and output specs
so we get the precision output that we
need for ourselves and for the customers
that and our partners that we give it to
in particular domains. I tried and Glenn
has tried to keep the skills mostly in
natural language so that anybody on the
team can work with them but there's SQL
and bash and go code and other things
associated with them as well but we
really tried to make it as codelike as
possible. So we're not going to have a
chance to go through all through all of
these things. Please talk to us
afterwards. I'll show you everything
that you can that we can show you. We're
going to talk about the tag triage skill
and the census enrichment ones in
detail, but let me talk about the other
ones. The threat hunting one is what
Orbeez is doing. So, you're going to see
that the output of that. So, we won't
talk about that much. We have a markdown
writing skill because it turns out
Claude sucks at markdown. It may look
like it does great job. It doesn't. So,
we actually had to build custom markdown
skills. So, it does really good
precision markdown that translates well
to PDF and to Google Docs.
Unfortunately, uh we do we have a pcap
analysis skill because we capture a ton
of pcap as Glenn mentioned and we need
to help it understand how to do work
with it. We're going to give it tools
too in a little bit to work with them
too. For anyone that works with out
ofband security testing domains, OT
domains, we give it a skill to know
everything it needs to know about those
domains and how to work with them and
tie infrastructure together with that
along with the MCP server. You'll see
soon too. Virus total, you all know what
that is. You wouldn't be here if you
didn't know what that is. and he's going
to drone on for like two minutes about
findings validation because he cares
about stuff like that. So I'll let him
do that later. Uh so this is uh the the
tag triage skill. It's how Orby works.
You can't read that. So basically if you
didn't get the URL before, go for it
there because you can see it. Uh we have
over 3500 detection rules tags. We need
to know what's important at any given
moment in time and especially like what
was important from yesterday to today or
over the weekend or even from a
particular defined time period. So
that's what we did. We we helped Ory
with the skill understand how to go do
what what it needed to go do to do that
and it gives me briefings on a regular
basis for those. One thing to kind of
call in mind there's been a theme
throughout the conference and it's kind
of it's kind of bittersweet to go last
for the whole talk but that gives us the
privilege of kind of pulling in some of
the conversations that have happened
earlier in the week. Um, but there's
been a theme of like how these skills
are so important and that, you know,
humans are still very involved in the
meaningful output using AI. And this is
actually a really good call out to that.
I don't really compliment Bob a lot in
person or virtually actually, but he
built this skill. So Bob has a data
science background. If you're not
familiar with his work, you've probably
seen it somewhere, but he built this
skill. The the language model didn't
figure out how we want to do the the uh
zscale analysis and stuff. So he built
the skill the skill that let Orbee do
the thing in a way that works for us. So
basically, you know, Bob is smart.
Sorry, I had to say that. Bob is smart,
but Orbeez is fast, working all the
time. So by putting those things
together, it was what really leveled up
the game. So just kind of another plus
one to what we've been hearing about how
skills and human-driven skills and
putting intentionality and kind of how
you develop those skills really matter
for for meaningful use of this.
>> So I'm slow.
>> Just move on.
>> I'm slow.
>> No, no, just move on. Okay. All right.
You you know Q1 review time.
>> I said you were smart. It's fine. Uh so
the one thing I want to call out to this
is this is completely modifiable. Uh he
created a preferences system for Orbee
that lets us tune it without changing
the core skills. And a little thing
happened on Saturday that everyone
probably realizes which changes things
up from an internet perspective. So we
actually worked with Orbee to craft a
specialized preferences to do an
analysis of conflict. basically anything
associated with the conflict. You can
talk to us about what it actually did.
This is an example of one of the things
it did to create what's out there. Those
are structured things that it outputs.
Again, we can talk about that there. But
we now can separate the conflict related
stuff from the rest of the stuff we have
to care about. By the way, while the
conflict's been going on and you're all
looking over there, the ransomware
attackers have been having a great time
building an inventory. So, you might
want to watch that in yours when you go
back. Uh the other one I want to give a
shout out to Census cuz we our data is
great. I love our data. We got great
insights from our data. And then when we
plugged census into this data, it
leveled it up like crazy. Uh they have
global, if you don't know who they are,
they've got global internet scan data.
It puts it at our fingertips and puts it
at Orbee's fingertips. We get to turn
IPs into full infrastructure profiles.
We use that as well as our Jaw 4, which
is a new way of identifying network
fingerprints and those O domains I
talked about. And we can map actual
attacker infrastructure better than we
have ever been able to do before. Well,
okay. Or or can to be honest about it.
And uh as an example, so you can see
that report there. And I want to just
call out this one because this is this
is this this is in the repo as well. It
found a cluster in a Canadian hosting
provider of it was a huge cluster and
2,000 of those nodes were slinging
gigantic scads of credentials against
sonic walls for the past 70 days. This
is something we just found last week. uh
we actually gave all this data to the
CCCS and they're hopefully going to shut
it down. Um along with that though uh we
actually worked with Orby the idiots did
leave their whole go profile like thing
but path open to their proxy network. So
we Orby and I managed to dig into it
profile the whole thing and we could see
exactly what it would go do. I kind of
want these proxies. They're really good.
I hate saying nice things about bad guys
but this is a really great proxy
network. You also try to tap into it
before they shut it down. Uh you know
about skills. So they're just text files
with SQL and bash and stuff. So I'm not
going to go into you saw that. I just
want to prove that we do work. So we've
been working for the past couple weeks
on modifying these things. I think we
tweak the skills almost every single
day. And do not judge me by my commit
messages. That is not nice. Don't don't
>> I'm judging.
>> Uh let's check in on Orbee. Oh wow. It
made it to phase four already. So it's
about to do the final report. It has
gone through grabbed that IP address.
Looked it up in census. looked it up in
virus total, combined it all together,
got the job for us, did whatever it
could, and we're going to see it
probably also did a bunch of fun stuff
on the back end that maybe we we might
not have done or done as fast. It's back
to the Matrix one more second. There's
that scene near the end where Trinity
and Neo drop into the pocket construct
and just load up guns, lots of guns, and
MCPs are that scene. an LLM with the
right tools and it can get the job done
really really well. So, Orby connects to
a dozen or so of these things. Some are
in-house. I'll walk through some of
them. Some we're converting to in-house
because reasons. And uh if you give it
access to the right data, it can do
things like, hey, here's an odd payload
and then give us a fully sourced
campaign investigation.
So, these are the tools that we give
that we gave it. There's a little more,
but these are the ones that matter the
most. Um, we work with ground truth
data. We've heard that a lot today which
I really appreciated hearing that other
people are doing that too. Archammy
which is kind of like wire sharkark for
the for internet scale data for us and
our great noise API data. Uh that's our
ground truth. That's where we need to
get things from. The Jaw 4 MCP server
has every single thing I know and he
knows and my team knows about Jaw 4
which are the fingerprints on the
network that these things talk to. This
helps us connect tissue in in the
infrastructure that's out there. Same
thing for the O domains. I worked with a
friend and customer over at Sandia. We
baked every single thing we know about
these domains into an MCP server, which
you're getting a link to today because
you all can use this. It's a command
line tool on MC.
>> You're going to want to dig into that. O
>> yeah, it's actually really important. Uh
we use duct DB for analytics because
friends don't let friends let LLM do
their own analytics because they suck at
everything if you don't give them tools.
uh Glenn and Glenn and myself and a
bunch of others have a ton of a a ton of
knowledge about how to do pcap analysis
and we gave it t-shark and wrapped an
MCP server around it with that 30 years
of information to let it dissect and do
what it can with pcaps because we
sometimes have to go into those too.
Serakata, same thing tool thing. Virus
Total, you know what that is. Uh, going
back to Census Platform and threat
hunting again, just just to shout out to
them. It's it's leveled up our analyses
and their MCP servers are awesome. We
did have to write that skill to use it
though, so it's kind of awesome. Uh, and
I get I also have to shout out to
Feedley. If you're not using Feedley
CTI, this is this is not a commercial.
It really provides all the external
context that we need to make this whole
thing really really smart.
And one last Matrix scene, since this
was threat hunting in the Matrix, near
the end, Neo sees that helicopter losing
control before it actually crashes. He
acts on what he sees coming, not what's
already happened. And that's the frame
for this section. Safety is prevention
and validation as detection.
So, going along with Bob's Matrix
reference because I was forced into
that. Uh, what happens when there's a
glitch in the matrix? And thinking about
this from the other side, for me it was
a confident wrong answer reaching a
stakeholder who then takes action on
that information. And in our space, this
can cause real harm, physical or
virtual. So how do we stop it from doing
dumb things? And then how do we get it
to tell it on itself or understand when
it does those dumb things anyway even
though we asked it not to?
So in the real world, we have guide
rails and guard rails. So kind of mimic
this a bit in our Orbee. Not I guess no
one else here is really named their
>> All right. Well,
>> you should.
>> Yeah, give it a name. It helps. Uh so
that in Orby it exists with like guard
hooks. So those are just shell commands
that were kind of policing the behavior
that the models, you know, you're like,
"Please don't do this, but it's going to
do it anyway." Um using a guard hook
kind of just terminates that process
right away and makes it move on. So it's
just a safety check. uh decision trees,
that's simply just going A to B to C to
make sure it's doing the order properly.
Um you can think of that as like you
can't have dessert before dinner. Uh
bulletproof patterns. Um we're
traditionally used to code which has
kind of a go no-go outcome, but writing
does not. And for like an example of a
bulletproof pattern we're using here is
just timestamp conversions. Like there's
a lot of ways to do that, but like don't
don't think about it. Just do do it this
way and move on, please. Uh and then
checklists. check. Uh I don't think it's
really surprising to think about AI
being very type A, but it helps to just
embrace that. So give it a checklist.
Make it a, you know, check these off as
you go. This is what you should do. And
then at the end, at least you're not
making assumptions about what it did
because you expected it to do it. Like
it will, you know, ensure that it at
least covered the bases that you had
expected it to do.
But those are the guardrails. But
guardrails don't prevent crashes. They
change just what happens after the crash
happens. And sometimes they can even
make the crash worse. So how do you
prepare for those eventual failures? You
crash test it. You build detections. So
in Orby, again, this looks like a few
things. Footnotes, like old school
footnotes, super helpful here. Um, you
can have a subject matter expert
reviewing a report had the footnote.
make the footnote really accessible like
with a URL or something to go to the
actual data source just you know check
for some hallucinations and you can get
a really quick feel for the vibe of the
report the accuracy and start building
or losing confidence in its output uh
logging everything we are cyber security
after all right um running assessments
this one's kind of fun you can kind of
think of it as therapy for your your
agent um you ask it like h how did how
did this go like what was hard for you
what could have made this better how
could we have sped this and it will
answer and it will engage with you. So
you can I mean don't get psychosis but
but so you can take that and then move
those findings further up in your skills
you know kind of shift left mentality to
make this work more effectively
downstream. uh the validator. I'm going
to touch on this on the next slide, but
essentially, you know, taking a finished
report, extracting every claim is how we
uh implemented this. And then using a
completely different model, revalidate
those claims and look for inaccuracies
and give feedback on, you know, maybe
it's a a 1% or half a percent off
because we're dealing with live data, so
when it re-queried, like there's more
now because it's been 10 minutes since
the last query, so that's okay. Um or
sometimes it's like, yeah, I did the
math wrong. My bad. I can't do, you
know, they they suck at dates maybe. Uh
and then we've heard this a lot this
week, which is extremely encouraging. A
human in the loop. You're still
responsible for the output of these
model of these uh reports. It's your
company. It's your brand. It's your
reputation, whatever. Um so you have to
stand behind it. You can't just
outsource all of that risk and liability
to that. So I think of this as a like if
you have a self-driving car and it
crashes into a street lamp, it's still
your problem. It's still going to be
your headache. you're still responsible
for what happened there.
So as soon as Orby started producing
real output, my first question was, you
know, how do again, how do we stand
behind this? How can I trust this thing?
And early on, I started engaging with
it, asking it questions. You how how how
do I know this is correct? Because now
you're calling yourself out. And it got
a little sassy with me, which I
appreciated actually. So I was like,
okay, we've got
>> So did I. So did I actually Yeah. Yeah.
We got we got some we got something to
work here. Um but yeah, so then I I
started making a skill for that. The
validator is clearly what we call it.
But um so running the validator on some
early reports uh it had some findings
like 78 claims extracted less than half
were verified. Like that's alarming. Uh
in one case it made up tag names. So for
grey noise tags are the root of our
findings and our output. Making up tag
names is really bad. Um and it turns out
after investigating that the model was
summ summarizing the tag names to try
and be helpful. But then by the end of
all of this run, the tag names were all
different. So it had made up a bunch of
tag names. So again, take that
information, put it in a skill, tell it
not to summarize or alternate K tag
names and problem solve. Um, so you just
have to kind of engage with it. And then
it also just added something to the SIS
code once. I can't explain that one. I
don't know if it has a crystal ball. I
should have actually checked to see if
it got added by now. But anyway, um,
that was interesting. But it was an easy
find because on the revalidation it was
like it's not there. Like all right, fix
it. Um, yeah. So, like I said, the goal
is just to reduce what the validation
finds by taking those learnings and
moving them further up in the chain.
>> Cool. So, we're pretty much almost at
time. So, I'll go through this real
quick just to show you it's a real
thing. These are linear tickets that
Orbeez created over the past round month
and a half uh when it's found stuff and
told us to go do things with it. And
it's really good at doing that cuz it
told me directly I'm supposed to go file
this GitHub takedown notice because it
found malware on GitHub and I had to go
do that. I don't like that because like
Microsoft never takes anything down. But
that's just another thing. At least it
had the nicity to give me what I should
tell it when I did that. And I actually
did it. I think that counts as human in
the loop though.
>> It might. It might. It did it. But then
I kind of restart the same session every
day to keep memory. So the next morning
I fired it up. It's like did did you
file that ticket? And like I had to
paste the URL for it to actually know
that I did that. So the era of our AI
overlords are actually here. I actually
don't need to go through this slide
because you've heard it from almost
everybody today. This is great. My one
takeaway. So, this is our manifesto. How
to design what your elements are going
to go do. It's all and this one's up
there as well, too. I'm just going to
say assume these things are going to do
something really stupid and plan around
it. G give it data, tell it what to do,
retell it what to do, tell it what not
to do. And then the last thing I'll say
is or the last one is also important to
save money. Uh we do the real hard work
on Opus 46 and we do all the lightweight
work on either Haiku or Sonnet to take
things a little bit cheaper.
>> It's been really cool this week to see
like we brushed over that slide really
quickly and all this is online so you
can see it later.
>> Oh and here it's running his stupid
findings valid. It takes so much time.
Who cares about validation? I mean
seriously.
>> But it's been cool this week to see how
we've all kind of come to the same
conclusions for that manifesto which is
why we can brush over it. So I think I'm
I'm I'm a little bit more optimistic at
the end of this conference than I was at
the beginning.
>> Yeah. So we're not going to go through
the report here. We didn't think we'd
have time for it. The report that it
made is up there. You'll see it. It's
pretty easily. You've got a skill you
can run against Census MCP server, which
you should do because it's got great
contextual data. You've got a free
Circata MCP server. If you work with
Circata, it's great for iterating
through testing rules and testing pcaps,
etc. And you've also got a OS domain
command line tool and MCP server as a
result of this too. So, you got a lot of
gifts
>> and this is all real too. So, like feel
free to use it and like go hunt and look
in your environment and
>> and this is how you get a hold of us. We
really suck at social media. So that
research at greyno.io is probably what
you should do. Um and feel free to you
know file issues and stuff on the GitHub
stuff because we're going to keep making
these things better and you can help us
make it better too. So thank you all.
Appreciate it.
Open source and a recap of the themes of
the day. Great way to end it. Let's do
questions.
>> Come on.
>> No question.
>> Oh, here we go. Great. There will be
questions. It always takes seven
seconds.
>> Actually, a question that I have been
wanting to ask and you're the lucky ones
to get it. So, everybody these days
seems to be using cloud code to
orchestrate the agents, work with the
agents. Have you thought and have you
tried to use like something like lang
graph lang chain instead of what is good
what is
>> that's an awesome question and as I
mentioned we have hit the limits of clog
code cuz it was meant for something else
completely different than what we're
trying to do with it. We worked with it
cuz it's free and it it's been great and
it's helped us get to where we are. We
need to create our own threat hunting
agent framework that knows what what to
go do. So you're yeah so we are
absolutely going to explore that. We are
probably going to try to do our own with
Go first because I like writing co Go
code weirdly enough. Actually, I like
Okay, that's not true anymore. I like
working with cloud code to write Go code
now. Uh I still like writing Go code,
but I like it better when it can help me
go do that. So yeah, that's a great
question and I would for anyone that's
trying to do this in house, start with
cloud code. It's the best thing out
there. You're going to outgrow it and
you should really consider moving to
something else. But the great thing is
you have a friend to help you. Like
Claude's my buddy and it can help you
guys do it, too. So it's great.
>> So a follow up to that. When do you
outgrow it?
>> When do I what
>> what are the limitations? What when do
you outgrow it?
>> When do you outrow it?
>> Oh, when do we outrow it? I think I
think so. This is Orbeez at 093 and I
think when I kind of get we have a
couple more things to tweak and after
1.0 I were going to be going to the next
thing because we need to expand it to do
other data and other sources. What it
can do now is great. I think that's when
we need to branch it out and do that.
It's
>> a lot about context window size.
>> Yeah. I like an because I I don't really
want to spend money on a million a
million token context window. I don't I
I like Anthropic a little but not that
much. I'm not going to give them that
much money. So,
>> anymore?
>> Nothing else. We're around. We can show
you the report. Go to the repo. It's all
yours.
>> All right. Thank you, man.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Thanks.